dis moi alors il ya longtemps que j'ai
envie de te faire le questionnaire de
proust au hall qui c'est celui-là tu vas
voir
pour quelle faute à tulle le plus
d'indulgence celle de se faire [ __ ]
qu'elle est un personnage historique
favori parent a reculé quelconque yahia
paie pas admettre qu'ils jouaient au
bilboquet way henri iii roi keïta
qualité préféré chez l'homme qu'elle se
fasse en tulle un petit peu de temps en
temps chez la femme aussi quelques
occupations préférées
[ __ ] les gens qui auraient tué m
à noter qu est ce que je suis apprécié
le plus chez les amis ah qu'est ce que
tu as voici le but c'était un ami qui
comprend six pas le défaut ne pas se
faire en tulle ce que tu déteste par
dessus tout ce qu'il faut pour le don de
la nature que tu me devrait avoir à
payer
comment aimerais tu mourir fois
à quels buts des vainqueurs
c'est qu'elle est qu'à devises ont tué
ou encore nous les uns les autres
alors bon j'arrête tête oui ça va ça va
on a trop tiré sur le salon avec leur
sérieux la question que j'ai posée
maintenant on n'est pas dans le
questionnaire de proust
sk tournage avec ce que tu t'en vois
quand même à moins à gérer sur et poli
bah oui mais enfin cigarettes alcool
quand même un d'accord est ce que tu as
besoin d'accessoires le maire michel
masset décédé je n'aime pas tellement
non je n'aime pas mal godemichet c'est
un petit peu comme une poupée que je
vais faire ma petite fille charlotte
ouais donc demain je vais offrir un
godemiché ouais mais je vais pas lui
fera comme ça j'aime et je n'ai pas deux
yeux du rouge à lèvres c'est sûr qu'avec
des poupées mon petit chéri mathieu
croit pas si bien dire regarde regarde
celui là